en septiembre de 2017 puerto rico-
sufrió el desastre natural más
importante en sus últimos 100 años
el impacto del huracán maría un enorme
ciclón de categoría 4 de un máximo de 5
con ráfagas de vientos superiores a los
250 kilómetros por hora lluvias
torrenciales causó estragos en la isla
la destrucción fue enorme miles de casas
fueron arrasadas y toda la red eléctrica
puertorriqueña quedó prácticamente
destruida la isla se quedó literalmente
a oscuras como os podéis imaginar los
daños económicos fueron gigantescos hoy
los costes de reconstrucción se estiman
en cerca de 100 mil millones de dólares
ah
[Música]
y no sólo eso siete meses después miles
de empresas continúan cerradas y los
apagones siguen siendo frecuentes sin
embargo amigos esperad un momento porque
hablar del huracán maría no es contar
toda la historia
[Música]
lo cierto es que los problemas de la
isla empezaron mucho pero que mucho
antes puerto rico- lleva más de 10 años
sufriendo una dura crisis económica y
todo un éxodo de población un éxodo tan
grande que amenaza la propia
supervivencia de la isla declarada en
quiebra en bancarrota en mayo de 2017 la
situación es tan crítica que el gobierno
de la isla está estudiando trasladar a
miles de presos a cárceles privadas de
los eeuu el motivo el gobierno de la
isla tiene problemas incluso para
financiar su sistema penitenciario y
alquilar plazas en lugares como texas o
florida es más económico
un momento prisioneros a eeuu si tal
cual como lo escucháis no olvidéis que
aunque ni siquiera muchos
estadounidenses lo sepan puerto rico-
forma parte de los eeuu no es un estado
sino un estado libre asociado con
derechos políticos muy limitados en este
vídeo amigos os contamos qué está
ocurriendo en esta isla situada en pleno
caribe atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bueno sabes
web
huila puesto
[Música]
cueto curioso lo correcto
en la vida de puerto rico
formando parte de los eeuu teniendo un
clima tropical una rica historia y
hermosas playas de arena blanca en las
que por cierto el mismísimo capitán
'jack sparrow' vivió algunas de sus más
célebres hazañas bien podríamos pensar
que puerto rico lo tiene todo para ser
uno de los lugares más prósperos del
mundo verdad pues espera su momento
amigos porque la realidad es muy
diferente precisamente en uno de
nuestros primeros vídeos en uno de los
primeros vídeos de visual político os
contamos por qué a puerto rico su
relación con eeuu le está causando
últimamente algún que otro problema al
final del vídeo y también en la
descripción os dejo el enlace al albor
de la ley d'hont
washington fijó una triple exención
municipal estatal y federal sobre los
intereses de la deuda pública de puerto
rico así si cualquier ciudadano
americano compraba deuda pública de
puerto rico- quedaba exento de pagar
impuestos sobre los intereses recibidos
por cierto que tiempos aquellos cuando
publicamos nuestro primer vídeo sobre
puerto rico apenas éramos mil 823
personas hoy la comunidad de visual
política tiene casi 600 mil suscriptores
en castellano y 4
en 2000 en inglés un millón que pasaba
de verdad una vez más gracias por estar
ahí pero continuemos
[Música]
amigos os hago una pregunta donde
pensáis que viven más puertorriqueños
parece una pregunta tonta verdad pues un
momento porque ya os adelanto que la
respuesta no es puerto rico
[Música]
la vida
si a primera vista puerto rico- puede
parecernos un paraíso para vivir buen
tiempo hermosas playas música sin
embargo amigos la isla tiene un problema
enorme cada año miles y miles de
puertorriqueños abandonan este lugar
veréis desde 1917 los puertorriqueños
son ciudadanos de los eeuu son
estadounidenses así que pueden moverse
por el país libremente pues bien según
los datos del pew research center
durante la última década más de 500.000
puertorriqueños han abandonado puerto
rico para mudarse al continente a
lugares como texas florida nueva york o
pennsylvania 500.000 personas es una
cifra enorme para una isla de poco más
de tres millones de habitantes visto de
otra forma tan solo en los últimos diez
años uno de cada siete habitantes se ha
marchado del puerto rico
os acordáis de la pregunta que os he
hecho hace un momento donde pensábamos
que vivían más puertorriqueños pues la
respuesta es que desde el año 2006 hay
más puertorriqueños viviendo en los
estados unidos continentales que en la
propia isla lo que estamos observando es
un importante proceso de despoblación
que no es muy común en la historia
moderna
lyman stones economista e investigador
sobre procesos migratorios y ojo porque
la cosa puede ponerse mucho pero que
mucho peor el propio gobierno de puerto
rico espera que tan sólo durante 2018
otros 200 mil 200 mil puertorriqueños se
marchen cuidado estamos hablando de que
puerto rico va a perder cerca del 6% de
su población en un solo año
[Música]
y amigos si este proceso este éxodo
estaba ya siendo vertiginoso las
consecuencias del huracán maría lo han
acelerado veréis diferentes estimaciones
tanto del gobierno como de consultoras
privadas esperan que tan solo durante
los próximos cinco años otro medio
millón de puertorriqueños hagan las
maletas y se marchen al continente estoy
muy apegado a mi isla y mi preferencia
sería quedarme aquí pero tengo que
pensar que es lo mejor para mi hijo
víctor domínguez banquero hipotecario de
39 años en declaraciones al washington
post y como os podéis imaginar semejante
huida de gente tiene consecuencias muy
serias para la isla entre otras cosas
porque los que más se marchan son
precisamente los más jóvenes de hecho se
calcula que la mitad la mitad de todos
los emigrantes de todas las personas que
han abandonado la isla tienen menos de
24 años en el resultado
durante la próxima década la población
de puerto rico se reducirá hasta los 2
millones y medio de personas es decir en
la próxima década puerto rico- perderá
800 mil habitantes el 25 por ciento de
su población atentos a esta previsión de
lyman stones
[Música]
y ojo porque de producirse otro desastre
natural otro huracán por ejemplo
esperemos que no o si la isla no
consigue recuperarse de la dura crisis
que atraviesa la realidad podría ser aún
peor os imagináis lo que esto va a
suponer para la economía de la isla
quién va a pagar su enorme deuda quién
va a pagar las pensiones
[Música]
y
pero amigos llegados a este punto creo
que nos tenemos que hacer una pregunta
porque se marchan tantos puertorriqueños
las estadísticas son propias de un país
en guerra pero en puerto rico no hay
ninguna guerra entonces qué está pasando
atentos
[Música]
una crisis muy larga
porque se marchan tantas personas de
puerto rico- amigos si echamos un
vistazo a los datos la explicación
parece muy clara casi la mitad de los
puertorriqueños que viven en la isla es
considerado pobre para los cánones de
eeuu claro el ingreso familiar medio es
de apenas 20 mil dólares que es algo
menos que la mitad del ingreso medio de
misisipí el estado más pobre de la parte
continental de eeuu
[Música]
pero no sólo eso además el gobierno de
la isla está en bancarrota y tiene una
deuda pública enorme 70.000 millones de
dólares y otros 50 mil millones en
compromisos de pago por ejemplo en
pensiones públicas recordad que estamos
hablando de una isla de poco más de 3
millones de habitantes una locura
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea de lo que
esto supone una familia media tendría
que destinar íntegramente seis años de
su salario para pagar la deuda pública
ahora ya podéis entender por qué puerto
rico- es conocida como la grecia del
caribe ahora bien pensáis que hemos
visto lo peor pues amigos estáis
equivocados
y lo peor de todo es que en puerto rico-
apenas hay trabajo
de hecho la isla tiene la tasa de
actividad más baja de los eeuu tan sólo
4 de cada 10 adultos trabajan o están
buscando trabajo y ojo si descontamos a
las personas que no tienen empleo y a
los trabajadores públicos cuyos salarios
salen de los impuestos de las personas
que trabajan en el sector privado
el resultado es para ponernos en alerta
menos de una cuarta parte de los
habitantes de la isla trabajan en el
sector privado
por cierto como curiosidad uno de los
grandes problemas de puerto rico- es
precisamente este los empleados públicos
los funcionarios fijáos casi uno de cada
cuatro empleos de la isla corresponde al
gobierno y eso no es lo peor
sabéis que muchos de estos empleados
públicos tenían el derecho a jubilarse
con 50 años 15 años antes que en el
resto de los eeuu
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y amigos si os gustan las películas de
miedo además podéis tener en cuenta que
como los jóvenes se marchan la población
de puerto rico- está envejeciendo muy
pero que muy rápido en otras palabras si
no cambian las cosas la situación de
puerto rico- se va a poner muy pero que
muy difícil pero vale llegados a este
punto estoy seguro que os estáis
haciendo una pregunta cómo diantres
puede la isla a salir de este berenjenal
hay realmente escapatoria veámoslo
[Música]
cómo salir de esta
se suele decir que aquellos que no son
capaces de aprender de la historia están
condenados a repetirla puede que algo de
esto ocurra en puerto rico- veréis
cuando hablamos de cómo ven los
políticos locales el futuro nos
encontramos con algo así como una de cal
y otra de arena con cosas buenas y cosas
no tan buenas puerto rico- ha quebrado
es un hecho y de seguir así el gobierno
puede llevar a la isla al abismo así que
por un lado es necesario recortar el
gasto público frenar la sangría que ha
provocado semejante deuda pública
y en principio el nuevo gobernador
ricardo ros ello está por la labor de
hecho se ha comprometido a reducir mucho
el tamaño del gobierno el problema es
que no está del todo claro como lo
quiere hacer es decir no está claro que
haya voluntad política para corregir los
grandes males de la isla
[Música]
por otro lado puerto rico- tiene que dar
un giro de 180 grados a su política
económica y poner en marcha planes
serios para atraer inversiones ojo
puerto rico- necesitan medidas decisivas
reformas de verdad no o cambios
cosméticos bueno hay que decir que en
los últimos años alguna cosa se ha hecho
por ejemplo aprovechándose de alguna que
otra laguna legal se está tratando de
convertir a puerto rico en una especie
de centro financiero que garantice el
anonimato a los inversores
internacionales
[Música]
es un buen camino pero hace falta
muchísimo más pero de todas formas
amigos de todo esto como creo que se nos
está terminando el tiempo hablaremos en
otro vídeo ahora bien antes de
despedirnos nos ha faltado una pregunta
muy importante que no podemos dejar sin
responder cómo diantres ha llegado
puerto rico- a esta situación pues bien
un motivo ha sido que los gobiernos
locales han gastado enormes cantidades
de dinero en contratar como hemos visto
a muchísimos trabajadores públicos y
también en carísimos proyectos en obras
faraónicas que no han aportado nada a la
isla nada más que deudas
menuda gestión el otro motivo tiene
mucho que ver con la influencia de eeuu
pero eso ya os lo contamos en este otro
vídeo así que ahora turno para ti y en
esta ocasión te voy a pedir que te mojes
crees que puerto rico debe seguir
perteneciendo a eeuu o debería buscar
convertirse en un país independiente
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta como siempre
si te han gustado el vídeo no olvides
darle a like y suscribirte al canal si
aún no lo has hecho un saludo y hasta la
próxima
dv
y los puestos
[Música]
web
rico
[Aplausos]
[Música]